I have a question.
Do we
us here in this room right now, not
some pie-in-the-sky
abstract we.
Not the ideal we. Speaking about us
right now in this room.
Do we need each other?
Huh?
That's a question.
Do we need each other?
Does Allah need us?
Do we need Allah?
Do we need each other?
We absolutely need each other.
We need each other more than we need our
own flesh and blood.
We need each other more than we need the
air that we breathe and the food that we
eat.
Because with each other,
we could battle hunger and starvation.
We could battle famine.
We could battle Iblis himself and all of
his troops.
But,
alone,
can any of us battle all of these
things?
Absolutely not.
[Silence]
Our prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us,
"The believer
to the believer
is the analogy
of a building.
Not just a wall, a whole building.
That is complete in its symmetry and
geometry.
Why, oh messenger of Allah? He says,
"Each
Each
strengthens and holds up the next.
Strengthens and holds up the next." Now,
this is
only if you are planning to go to
paradise.
If your ultimate goal is to reach
paradise,
you need your brothers and you don't
have enough to just give away or
squander. You need every single one of
them.
However,
if your goal is to, you know, live
comfortably, just you know, leave me
be, leave me with my big screen TV, and
leave me with my with my
chrome-plated toaster oven and and
leave me with my nice fancy car and you
know, I don't want to rock the boat. I
don't want problems with anybody.
Anything that comes up or arises, I just
don't want to hear about it. I'll just
excuse myself. That kind of thing. Well,
then brotherhood might be a little bit
difficult to keep up with for that.
However, if you are planning to get to
paradise and get through the gates of
paradise,
you need your brothers.
You need your sisters and you don't need
of them their mistakes. You need of them
the best that they can be and the best
that they can offer.
If we were to say right now, does a
person need a mother, need a father in
order to survive, in order to live? Not
necessarily. As a matter of fact, our
prophet Muhammad was
was an orphan, right? He had lost both
both of his parents.
But he turned out how he turned out.
Many scholars, some of the greatest
scholars, a Shafi was an orphan.
Right?
However, we need our Muslim brothers and
our Muslim sisters.
And if our mother and our father are
Muslims and our children are Muslim and
our siblings are Muslim and our family
members are Muslim, then we need them
doubly.
We need them twice folds.
One for their
the Islam that is in their heart and two
for the rahim and blood that courses
through their veins.
Listen to this narration.
So, Sa'd ibn Malik, do we know who Sa'd
ibn Malik is?
All of us know Sa'd ibn Malik. I'll I'll
use a different name. Sa'd ibn Abi
Waqqas. Do we know Sa'd ibn Abi Waqqas?
Yes.
One of the 10
people mubashareen bil Jannah.
So,
as the Battle of
Badr concluded and finished,
of course,
there are,
you know, the fallen
troops of the opposing army.
[Arabic recitation]
came with all this fancy equipment,
right?
State-of-the-art armor, state-of-the-art
swords and spears and
And so,
you know, for someone who is planning to
spend the next decade in
combat,
these are important tools, and these are
very exciting tools.
So, Sa'd ibn ibn Malik, Sa'd ibn Abi
Waqqas, he found a sword that he really
liked.
I mean, he really was captivated by this
sword.
So, he took it,
and he raised it,
and he said, "Ya Rasul Allah,
ij'al hadhihi li."
Now, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam goes way back with Sa'd ibn Abi
Waqqas,
even before Islam.
And their lineage also
also meets.
And so,
he said, "Please give me this sword.
Make it for me."
And so, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala sent
down the verse.
And he had a a bit of a squabble with
some other companions over this sword.
You know, it was a nice sword, so they
were kind of
you know, in conflict with each other.
They were arguing over this sword.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent
down the verse.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala responded to
this squabble here.
And he said, "They ask you
for the spoils of war.
They ask you about the spoils of war.
They ask you how they will be divided.
They ask you for this and that. Tell
them the spoils of war belong to Allah
and his messenger.
Not this to this one and this to the No,
all of them belong to Allah and his
messenger.
Have we settled that? He says,
"So obey Allah
He says, "So fear Allah. Obey Allah.
Revere Allah and
correct, make amends.
Not just between one another,
but get to the core of the issue between
each other and weed it out."
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
what I said to you what I said to you
that I mean
What I said to you mean and
make amends with one another, right?
Squash your problems
with each other.
However, what I said to you
that I mean to you
it means
don't just superficially
topically
resolve issues
while they are simmering underneath
because the underlying issue has not
been corrected or addressed.
Rather, get to the root of the issues
between you and weed those issues out.
Right? There is a big difference between
those two statements.
If we were if this were a medical issue
we would say the difference between
between what I said to you
what I said to you that I mean to you
would be someone
who is suffering from
a virus
or a flu, let's say, and as a result
they have a fever.
What I said to you what I said to you
that I mean to you
would be to put
and a cool rag
and take some, you know, Tylenol or
something to get the fever down. That is
what I said to you what I said to you
that
They still have the flu.
They still have the virus. They're still
sick.
But they've remedied the immediate
fever.
What I said to you what I said to you
that I mean to you
would literally be to course through the
and purged
of its underlying illness.
That is the difference between these
two.
Right?
We are very good at what uslihu
baynakum.
We're really good at maybe not really
good. We're pretty good at what uslihu
baynakum.
Right?
Topically addressing issues.
We wait until brothers are at blows with
one another.
Then maybe we'll sit them down and we'll
try to get them to reconcile and we'll
just say, "Okay, guys. You know, you
Whatever. Don't worry about it. Just
Just shake hands and let's be okay with
this." And so they get up and
reluctantly shake hands and they leave
and then they are from that point on
more times than not their
relationship is irreparably damaged.
And they just don't want to get into it
and it's just not worth it. And And this
is very similar to the kind of workplace
peace that we make with one another.
At my workplace, let's say we work in a
factory together. I have two factory
workers that are conflicting, that are
fighting with each other. I don't need
them to agree and make peace
deeply
at the deepest level. I just need them
to get along enough to make the factory
work.
I just need them to get along enough
to make the
assembly line run.
That is a topical addressing of the
issue.
However, we notice here in this verse
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
yas'alunaka anil anfal.
Qulil anfal lillahi wal rasul. So Allah
didn't begin with make peace with one
another.
What did he begin with?
Addressing the real
the real
source of the problem. The source of the
problem was this sword. The source of
the problem was this and fell these
spoils of war. And so, what did Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala do? He took it all
away.
Neither of them got it.
And they learned a lesson
that when we fight, we all lose.
Everyone loses when we fight.
And so, this isn't the first time that
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
addressed conflict amongst the
companions in this way.
And sahih al-Imam Muslim, the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was
it was the last 10 nights of Ramadan.
And you know, his hujra was very close
to
the
the minbar and the front of the
masjid. Any of us who've been to Medina
masjid, we see the the
the distance the distance isn't much
farther from here to that wall,
right? And so, when they would pray
together,
he would get up and go into his hujra,
and
the companions would still be there
where they prayed, and they would have a
conversation, they would talk, they
would discuss things, and he could hear
them.
And so, one night, they were in the last
10 nights, they were discussing a very
important issue, and that is which night
is going to be Laylatul Qadr.
Right? And so, they were discussing
this, debating this with one another.
Each has his evidence, each
arguing his point.
And then they started to get personal
about it.
And they started to get upset with each
other. And they started to fight with
each other, two of them.
And so the prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam came out and he said,
"I knew which night Laylat al-Qadr was
going to be
this year.
And then Allah lifted that knowledge
from me.
He took it back.
Why did he took it take it back?
What was the reason he took that
knowledge back?
It wasn't knowledge, you know, of the
legislation. It was knowledge of that
particular year.
He took it back
because of their argument.
When they argued, when they disagreed,
when there was animosity in their
hearts, they were all punished together
because the Muslimin are whole. Could
you imagine
imagine how big of a deal that is.
Imagine we were sitting with the the
prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam and
he would was going to identify for us
which night is Laylat al-Qadr.
That's some pretty important
information, right? What would you do if
you knew for a fact Laylat al-Qadr is
going to be tomorrow night for a fact?
Allah himself has informed us that
tomorrow night is Laylat al-Qadr. How
valuable would that information be?
However,
that was taken back.
Why? Because of the argument. And so the
companions learned a lesson. What was
that lesson?
When we
when we
turn on each other, even slightly,
immediately we all suffer and there are
no winners. We are all losers when we
turn on each other.
That is the lesson that is learned.
Yes,
they're asking you about al-anfal. Tell
them that al-anfal belong to Allah and
his messenger.
Don't worry about that. None of you is
going to get this. What you were
fighting about, it's now been taken
away. You're not going to get it.
Someone else who had nothing to do with
this will eventually get that.
And this was before
the,
, rulings of the division of the
spoils of war were was revealed. This is
the first major battle. This is the
first battle that they had spoils of
war.
And so, the point here that is is being
made is, "Well,
that be me come." It is not an option.
This verse is not saying, "You know,
it's better if you make peace with your
brother." That's not what the verse
says. It is positively obligatory upon
you.
And if you do not,
and if you make just some superficial,
,
thing, you know, superficial remedy for
the situation with one another, but you
don't remedy the, the, the real
underlying core issue, this will affect
both of you.
In the 15th night of Sha'ban,
Allah looks upon his creation and
forgives every single Muslim except for
two.
Who knows these two?
Two brothers that are
mutashahhinan ash-shahna.
Right?
Two Muslims that are at odds with each
other.
Allah says, "These two
they are not forgiven on this night.
Wait until they make peace with each
other."
How long could that be? Well, if it's
until they die, then it's until they
die. They missed out. That's gone.
And the other one is is who?
Huh?
A mushrik?
A very specific type of mushrik.
A sahir.
Someone who deals with magic
or shirk. There's
varying narrations, but these are all
involved.
On Thursdays and
the person's deeds are raised and
exhibited to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
If two people are at odds with each
other, Allah does not accept to see
their deeds until they make peace.
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
said
that
if you
boycott
if you abandon your Muslim brother
for a year
you are guilty of shedding his blood.
You are guilty of killing him.
How guilty is that? It's very guilty.
Because
this is exactly the kind of things that
will break us down
make us into bite-size pieces for our
enemies to come by and just swallow us
up very easily.
Right? We needed each other. And the
fact that we have each other is a
blessing. We don't do this, well, I can
find someone else. I can replace him. I
can get someone else. I don't need this
one. I don't need that one. We need each
other. We have to make this work.
If we were on a life raft with each
other,
and it was not the ideal life life raft,
and it had holes in it, and it was
rickety, we will fix it. We will make it
work.
That is the situation that we are in.
This is not a suggestion in Islam. This
is one of the greater obligations upon
every Muslim.
[Silence]
I mean.
What do you mean?
Do you mean the thing we'll go through
it the same way?